bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
tornati solidi isole shaun tenetevi
pronti lega perché non ho capito se mi
fa più paura alien o un piatto di pasta
di mia nonna però lascio gioco che è
meglio
ragazzi questo è il 46 e pullman che
prendo io anno si sta schiantando merda
mozione stanno andando a notte ne andare
così se mi devono far contattare la mia
nave ma che milionì su un telefono che
prenda cosa del genere non lo so se per
caso la turris ha voglia di farsi una
partita regala tanto lì che è amica mese
fa ci fosse qualcuno che puntasse una
torcia addosso fantastico che aprì
condotto fantastico devo per forza a
buttarmi nel va bene non mi piace fare
cose perché non so mai dove vada a
finire soprattutto se mi si chiude il
condotto sopra la testa una torcia un
qualcosa di decente per potermi di 20
ragazzi e ami un attimo che non ho
capito dove aprì condotto perfetto ma
perché ogni volta che succedono ste cose
mi piglio male perché non so dove questo
andato dove siamo perse posti
completamente diverso detto questo si
chiede osservazione share lo è anche se
non c'è qualcosa successo qui no allora
sentite no tu no tu no lurido stronzo
che cosa è un tizio che è passato a caso
di corsa buongiorno senta lei buon uomo
ma dove vanno a finire se non è corrono
a tutta velocità contro il muro e poi
tipo harry potter posso andare altra
parte non lo so spariscono questo morto
riga non lo voglio neanche scoprire va
bene sono tagliatelle di alien isole
show ci gioco col computer ci gioco la
playstation
buongiorno già lei non si placa basta
non lo voglio
cazzo è la parola più giusta vita mia in
tale lei non capito se una donna un uomo
che capelli lunghi comunque c'è una
chiave inglese
ma qualcosa mi dice che non sa come
usarla però va bene riuscisse ad entrare
dentro in qualche modo non lo so
anche se non che a perfetto trovato ho
trovato il passaggio fantastico
ma perché mi deve ispirare nei condotti
non mi piace sta cosa li condotti prima
o poi succede
io sono convinto ecco eccolo qui lo
sapete cos'è che cazzo succede terminato
a sei tu sei tu che hai pagato nel conto
è dirlo prima sei molto bello però io ti
devo prendere questo e grazie grazie
credo che serva pm che te ma io gli
darei anche una botta in testa zia non
so se sei d'accordo non è poi così bella
si può aprire togli la spranga impronta
a ok premia mica bisogna essere
ingegneri per aprire le porte in sto
gioco fantastica bene era importante che
sia aperta comunque ragazzi si capisce
tantissimo che questo gioco e surreale
perché hanno tradotto una roba in
italiano e non è mai successo nella
storia che una città cosa che data in
italia non mai la sostanza è veramente
allegra il mio prossimo compleanno lo
faccio qua dentro ragazza romana ormai
sicuro prima volta che mi rimane questa
che chiedevo ancora che non cinematica
per sbloccare una porta dito stai ferma
salverà già allora già è una giornata di
merda cioè non tisci mettere pure tu con
le piste tra l'altro casa e macho
cappato non cammina più da dove arrivi
ripley da fuori non ci sono navi ma
lunghezza
quello è l'ultimo dei nostri problemi sì
sì c'è qualcosa su questa stazione non
ci crederesti mai sono i teletubbies
lega capisci ok ma perché mi deve
puntare la pistola in faccia e la cosa
non l'ha capita stavo salendo apporto
punto con echi le esplosioni già
separati e io ti a trovarmi perché
sembri conosce così ma perché che ci
guadagno ti do 20 dollari non era a
seggi trigate tesoro lo dici a tua
sorella innanzi tutto qua ci dobbiamo
chiarire denti se non vuoi che ti prende
a calci nel culo che non usi la tua
testa come palla da bowling alla prima
occasione legaioli fico una testata mi
piola pistola come se niente fosse tipo
adesso se n'è accorto tagliate continua
buongiorno che cosa fa presente che là
fuori ha visto la mia volta il babbo
natale e le adoro quando i videogiochi
sono seri ragazzi e chi si è stato così
a crisi sono tutti terrorizzati
ognuno pensa a se siamo rimasti solo noi
due ma perché ha sondato la nostra
deficiente i tristi la corrente sentito
dimmi che sei un elettricista almeno
quel bravo bravo almeno non sei
totalmente inutile come la carta
igienica
ma che fa sempre un po utile la carta
igienica lo è c'ero già stato qui
incazzo
dobbiamo muoverci senti tu non mi dà gli
ordini neanche se alzate dovremmo
cercare una via d'uscita che mi hanno
visto il suo gioco sono state quanto
nelle fante ma non importa poiché ok
bravo grappa siamo di no perché la
pistola
mi chiedo se fossi lì la prenderei
sparare in faccia solo non è perché sono
cattivo e perché sono stronzo ecco
perché guardare il tuo culo mentre ma
davanti non è una bella vista dice che
c'è una torcia co in giro ma non la sto
vedendo ciò che è bello ma così son
cuffie non è una frase tu hai capito
male il concetto di torcia zio queste
son cuffie cioè non è che sta roba fa a
far luce spenta come lei però sono
cuffie 20k pelata che tu non ce l'hai la
torcia verona che mi posso far vedere
lui vedo solo io praticamente minchia
funziona festeggiata devo riuscire usa
la torcia per trovare entrata nel
condotto questa entrata arrivo o già
trovato mezzo se con mica sono un
fenomeno manco sherlock holmes
se io riuscissi ragazzi ad andare sito
zita lo dici a tua mamma e forse a tua
zia ma non a me di sicuro si accendono
gli schiaffi che io quando quando kimi
libero di lui in qualche modo gli parlò
prendo a calci dà troppo fastidio che mi
dice quello che devo fare
non avete idea del cazzo sono andati con
cosa cazzo stai facendo ragazzi ci sono
dei tizi che ci hanno visto malissimo ci
stanno già puntando che cazzo fai piano
che ci stanno più s'angelo cerca un modo
per distrarre i saccheggiatori sono
saccheggiatori questi vorresti dire che
mi sto pagando addosso io non so io non
sono un bravissimo nei giochi stealth e
quindi mi caricava come fanno due decimi
non è possibile veramente di vista sono
messi male forte ci dovrei ci dovrei
essere ragazzi però non ho capito questo
con più a spegne cosa spegne generatore
si è già fatta
abbiamo trovato sono un fenomeno manco
splinter cell ragazzi che cazzo succede
adesso niente arrivato babbo natale
si è spento da solo no merda ragazzi
stanno vedendo
buongiorno sentite è un problema che
come faccio a seminarli cazzo cazzo
cazzo
ok allora sentite un attimo ragazzo che
potrebbe essere un problema il fatto che
non ho pensato a dove nascondermi prima
di spegnere adesso che si è fermato sono
un genio se non c'è io sono genere ce ne
sono un [ __ ] calmo fantino questa
l'ho sentita merda e vabbè dai siete ma
non si spara una ragazza solo perché già
le dette piccole non è possibile centra
ghana la cosa dovete morire
si no
[Musica]
non hanno visto mano visto sì sì perché
se lo fanno non far non so neanche come
abbiano fatto a non vederlo mi caccia si
fanno vedere una che corre scappa con
axel no no sinceramente vorrei scappare
con qualsiasi persona tranne che con
magari con megan fox ma non con ace
bloccato ci hanno isolati si vabbè senti
tu che sei elettricista fa qualcosa
temporaneamente io mi occupo di questa
che è pronto zio a premi l'interruttore
di azione vai al mio 32 a comprimere io
proprio io ero pino lo zio ha tempo o io
non ho fatto un cazzo ne so non fosse un
tutto lo venite qui wrestling
professionale ragazze cosa mi se io
posso prendere a calci sto tizio tremiti
ok è morto cossiga si poteva tirarsi
anche una una kia vietata in testa merda
io io col correrei se può sempre
perfetto scappa con altri ragazzi è una
cosa bellissima sa che dobbiamo correre
ma scappare da esseri umani anche da da
alien perché stava può vedere me mi hai
salvato la vita e ho capito è questione
di sopravvivenza è questa qua si sta
scandalizzando perché molto un tizio
quando c'è alien che gira nella va bene
c'è qualcosa si prega maker ho mai lega
porca [ __ ] ragazzi il cazzo
ok caso detto alien perfetto devo
proseguire l'agenzia stazione come se
non fosse successo niente proprio che
hai aprista porta [ __ ]
ok ce l'abbiamo fatta perfetti
ringraziando iddio trovo un ascensore
sampson communication
ok procura non me ne frega tanto le
lascia il sole ma di non incontrare quel
tizio di caldo treno italo alta velocità
99 e quindi c'e in partenza al binario 4
chi cazzo è sto tizio sarà in culo ai
lupi riunito in direttissima chiesti
parla giorno senta lei non mi puntare
aria da eva 6 puntar che pezzo di mer
tu vai no no non scassa mica perché sono
ancora vivo prego beccato un proiettile
in faccia ma sono ancora vivo si può
passare di qua a sintetizzatori si
ascolta siamo nel momento di farsi le
pippe su sintetizzatori per accesso in
questo momento proprio a diventare che
non capisce buongiorno a chi è palle ma
perché la gente deve sparare
[ __ ] per morire la sorella mi ero
dimenticato che c'era il tizio in
qualche modo riuscirò a raggirare steed
efficienti di meco perfetto ma sei
stronzo nel cervello [ __ ] anche
preso no mi chiamo schivato crocione
infatti mi ammazzate un'altra volta giù
di schiaffi in una maniera in cui io ve
lo dico a di qua nodi con la sega di qua
un e se card e fine con dargli pare che
no no no no no no non prendi questo per
caso si no c'è la porta c'era la porta
si no no no no no no no no non lo si è
girato s'è girato s'è girato ma mi ha
visto mia testa mi ha vista invece mi
ricordo se io sì se si arriva dove vado
chi cazzo è quello a ragazza e passa a
tutti salve ogni sacrosanta volta che
vado avanti c'è gente brutta
fatemi entrare perché non ne posso più
duro belle scarpe la pistola non ci
crederò mai che ha visto veramente
ragazzo no un ragazzo felice ascom e
ragazzi sto che ha detto che torno
indietro mi spareranno in faccia limite
subito hanno persone indietro cos'è sta
roba bongiorno cioè bella ok c'è più
che cazzo sta succedendo perché si
muovono mandato
l'alieno tanto bello nello scatto per
dire qualcosa che cazzo c'è di strano
che sta facendo nessun da associati file
danneggiati
ho capito registrato un video è lì si
sono cancellati da della mia stessa
reazione quando registro video non melis
ago uguali qualcuno mi spieghi la
cellula tasco trovata lo trova prefetto
trovo disabilitato qualcosa che non
incazzo fa sentire nel momento di
giocare al computer ma a salve io ho un
revolver
io sono o no non ti cagano addosso
adesso perché non è il momento per gara
porca [ __ ]
ok sono o sono vivo solo perfetto
ascolta zio potrei a venerdì con la coda
all'attaccapanni però doveva perché ce
l'aveva con la scrivania è salito
madonna quanto sei bello kiss italia
2015 caso non si sa come sia possibile
che una ragazza così bella sia andata
via però io ti amo torna qui io sono
convintissimo che in realtà li anziana
una donzella da rimorchiare ragazzi no
tranquilli tranquilli che vuole solo
giocare
vabbè c'è un modo tutto suo di farlo
ovviamente ognuno c'ha i cazzi suoi
scortati al girone ma non chi ok ecco
perfetto adesso siamo amici non lo so io
chiedo così non che fa
no no no salve ma ricordati che ti ho
dato un atto ha dato una mano io si è
fatto un chilometro di corsa poi torna
indietro ok va bene non faccio domande
che me sapevo che non dovevo stare zitto
cazzo e [ __ ] però sei stronzo
c'è questo è successo
d'accordo ragazzi conclude piso adesso
che siamo entrati in contatto con la
bellissima e in nettissima alien dove
siano oggi il gioco sarà tipo mezzo
stesso horror quindi non voglio neanche
sapere come va a finire prova bravi
ragazzi se il video mi è piaciuto fa
seguito al suo documento mi piace anche
forse di facebook e come noi vi trovate
nella descrizione forse dovresti
destinazioni ci rimettiamo il prossimo
video delle ragazze